the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so for this particulate so for this last
class exercise we have this following
code so we have 46 for USA Gold 427 for
UK gold one for Romania gold we make
this variable here total gold to be the
sum of those three which I believe is
seventy four then we're going to print
total gold okay then we're going to
increase the value for Romania golden
we're going to print it again so as
always you can just copy this pop it
into python and run it to test yourself
but you should you should you should do
it just in your mind first so notice
that print 74 and 74 and that's because
we never told the program to calculate
the new total right so we only
calculated the total way up here on line
5 if we calculated the total again down
here then it would be 74 75 so let's
look at the answers hopefully you guys
got that perfect majority are are good
to go if you didn't get that please try
to review it review why it didn't work
okay